these are just two of 90 recommendations
made by the european citizens panels on
democracy values and rights and
environment climate and health
all part of the conference on the future
of europe
representatives from these two panels
championed their recommendations at the
conference plenary their ideas are the
fruit of six weekend's work dozens of
grassroots events and thousands of ideas
posted online i'm wearing a thin mask to
talk today because of kovid but i don't
want future generations to wear a gas
mask to protect themselves from
pollution because capable institutions
couldn't be bothered to take actions
when they could joining them for the
debates were members of the european and
national parliaments eu institutions
trades unions and other stakeholders
it's based on these recommendations that
we need to formulate proposals and
conclusions for the conference
the two final meetings of the european
citizens panels will be held in dublin
and maastricht in february the plenary
will take all panels recommendations and
prepare proposals for the future of
europe
[Music]
you